fabien gay sénateurs pcf de
seine-saint-denis justement bonjour
fabien gay merci d'être avec nous cet
après midi sur rt france alors on l'a vu
ras le département de cette zone y est
particulièrement touchée aussi par le
cos vide 19le le département le plus
touché d'île de france
est ce que le département est préparé à
cette vague de mortalité
il est comme le reste de la france
d'abord il faut rendre hommage au
personnel soignant qui s'activent qui a
dévouement sans faille et un
professionnalisme hors normes dans une
situation tout à fait exceptionnelle et
l'internement précédente avait raison
nous sommes moins bien doté que le reste
de l'ile-de-france dans tous les
domaines dans tous les services publics
et notamment nos services publics
hospitaliers qui manque de vie qui
manquent de matériel comme partout sur
le territoire
mais encore plus en seine saint denis je
rappelle qu'il y a maintenant quelques
mois le premier ministre avait dit pour
la première fois que l'état reconnaissez
des défaillances en seine saint denis
dans tous les services publics et que
contrairement à ce que l'on croit
il y a moins ce que le service public
est moins d'argent en seine saint denis
que or ni de partout ailleurs en france
et notamment en ile de france et c'est
ces inégalités très forte que nous
vivons au quotidien et qui ressorte
encore plus forte au moment d'une crise
sanitaire
mais il ya aussi beaucoup d'autres
phénomènes la promiscuité on en a parlé
on a parlé aussi de réseaux sociaux
professionnels vous savez celles et ceux
qu'on appelle les invisibles celles et
ceux en réalité qui sont nos premiers de
cordée dans cette crise sanitaire
beaucoup à 87 cents et beaucoup sont au
travail aujourd'hui ce sont des
soignantes
ce sont des aides-soignantes ce sont des
livreurs ce sont des gens les éboueurs
ce sont celles et ceux qui font vivre
nos supermarchés notamment les
caissières les caissiers et oui il y a
plus de mortalité parce que vous l'avez
vu la semaine dernière nous avons une
caissière est morte à saigner
nous avons un agent de sécurité qui est
mort on est sous bois et donc il y avait
urgence partout sur le territoire
mais encore plus s'en servir nous avait
promis jeudi un plan de rattrapage
il ne faut pas qu'il soit renvoyé aux
calendes grecques après la crise il faut
que les profs justement fabien l'air
comment vous explorerez ans
comment vous expliquez que cette
urgentes soient plus présents
particulièrement au sein de syndic dans
d'autres départements français pourquoi
la seine saint denis est principalement
les parce ce que je disais à l'instant
c'est que nous sommes moins bien dotées
en service public
nous avons moins de médecins de ville
nous avons eu c'est vrai vous avez moins
de moins de moyens comment vous
l'expliquez vous avez mon moyen moins de
médecins et personnels de santé mais
parce que notre territoire c'est ce que
je disais à l'instant est frappé de
fortes inégalités et que là aussi l'état
a été défaillant sur 30 ou 40 ans ce
n'est pas que la faute au gouvernement
maintenant mais je rends hommage à tous
les fonctionnaires qui malgré des
difficultés sont en pointe aujourd'hui
dans ce combat qui les anime pour
protéger notre population et pour les
soigner mais c'est structurel je dirais
la seine saint denis en moins
qu'ailleurs et donc dans cette crise
sanitaire
évidemment comme sur l'ensemble du
territoire il faut des moyens
exceptionnels mais il en faut un peu
plus
en seine-saint-denis parce que la
pénalité l'extrême pauvreté qui touche
plus qu'ailleurs une grande partie de
notre population
les met en position de très grande
agilité vous aviez dit tout à l'heure
vous avez parlé du gouvernement qui a
reconnu l'urgence 1
dans le département de seine-saint-denis
est-ce que vous pensez que cette crise
sanitaire et économique va justement
permettre de pouvoir faire la lumière
sur ce qui se passe actuellement en
seine-saint-denis et permettre aussi au
gouvernement de mettre les moyens dans
ce département
vous savez ça fait plusieurs mois que
les élus locaux les parlementaires je
dirais de tout l'arc politiques se sont
rassemblés pour pour dire que cela
suffisait qu'il fallait un plan
d'urgence et comme je le rappelais il ya
quelques mois le petit est venu avec
plusieurs ministres mais pour dire que
notamment en termes de santé d'éducation
de police est justice il y allait avoir
un plan de rattrapage
mais ce plan de rattrapage il faut qu'il
soit dès maintenant et que des moyens
exceptionnels soit débloquée
d'événements merci beaucoup fabien gay
d'avoir été avec nous cet après midi sur
rt frange rappel et que vous êtes
sénateur pcf de seine-saint-denis merci
beaucoup